[indistinct chatter
over police radio]
[camera shutter clicks]
- IT'S A WEIRD ONE--
NOTHING OUT OF PLACE,
NO MURDER WEAPON.
- AND NO MOTIVE.
THERE'S JUST A COUPLE
LYING DEAD IN THEIR BED.
- THE PROOF IS ALWAYS
OUT THERE, DETECTIVES.
YOU JUST HAVE TO KNOW
WHERE TO FIND THE PUDDING.
- EXCUSE ME, SIR, YOU CAN'T BE
HERE--THIS IS A CRIME SCENE.
- SAMWELL, IT'S OKAY.
HE'S THE GREATEST SEX-CRIME
INVESTIGATOR IN HISTORY.
IF IT ISN'T
DETECTIVE CHUCK VAUGHAN.
- DETECTIVE SALLY FERGUSON.
- WE COULD USE A GENIUS
RIGHT NOW.
- TOM SAMWELL.
- WHAT HAVE WE GOT, SAMWELL?
- WELL, VAUGHAN, WE'VE GOT
OURSELVES A HARD CASE HERE.
ALL WE'VE GOT IS--
- TWO BODIES, BOTH DEAD, NAKED--
ONE MAN, ONE WOMAN IN THE BED,
TWO SCENTED CANDLES
BY THE NIGHTSTAND.
- HOW DID YOU--
- SHH.
- NO SIGN OF FORCED ENTRY.
HE LOVED THE WAY THEY SMELLED.
[sniffing]
HE WANTED TO CROSS
THE THRESHOLD
THE WAY THEY HAD
ON THEIR WEDDING DAY.
[sighs]
YOU DIRTY DOG.
[chuckles]
HE WOULD'VE EXPERIENCED
THAT PLEASURE RIGHT HERE.
[pants unzip]
[groaning loudly]
ANNIVERSARY--THE COUPLE
WAS TOGETHER FOR A WHILE,
WANTED TO SPICE THINGS UP.
CHECK THE DATE
ON THE PHOTOGRAPH.
- VAUGHAN'S RIGHT.
TODAY WAS THEIR 15TH WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY.
THIS IS HUGE.
- AND WHAT THE [bleep]
WAS THAT?
YOU JUST PULLED YOUR DICK OUT
AND STARTED JERKING OFF
AT THE CRIME SCENE.
- SAMWELL,
HE'S THE BEST THERE IS.
BY PUTTING HIMSELF
IN THE PERPETRATOR'S MIND-SET,
HE'S ABLE TO SOLVE CRIMES
THAT INVOLVE SEX.
BAG THIS UP.
- SOME CALL IT A BLESSING.
IT'S MORE LIKE A CURSE.
- IS THAT WHAT IT FEELS LIKE?
- [sniffing]
THREESOME.
[sighs]
YOU WANTED TO SEE THEM,
DIDN'T YOU?
YOU WANTED TO WATCH.
25 FEET FROM THE BEDROOM,
ACROSS THE KITCHEN, YOU...
[huffing]
YOU DIDN'T WANT
TO SEE THEIR FLESH YET, DID YOU?
NO. HE STOOD RIGHT HERE.
[pants unzip]
[groaning loudly]
ROLE PLAY GONE WRONG.
CHECK THE LOGS.
- WE'VE GOT A BLOODY FIRE POKER.
WE'VE GOT OUR MURDER WEAPON.
- UM, WHY DO YOUR REVELATIONS
REQUIRE MASTURBATION?
- WHY DO KITTENS REQUIRE MILK?
- NOPE, NOT THE SAME THING.
- HEY.
HEY, HE'S THE MOST BRILLIANT
GODDAMN DETECTIVE I KNOW.
PUT YOUR EGO ASIDE
AND GIVE VAUGHAN HIS SPACE.
- MY EGO?
WE GOT CAPTAIN PUDPULLER
FLINGING HIS FLUIDS
ALL OVER THE CRIME SCENE.
- WAIT.
HE KNEW THEM.
HE--
THEY WERE CLOSE, SO CLOSE,
TOO CLOSE.
HE--HE...
I THINK HE KNEW THE HOUSE.
WHY?
WHAT DID YOU WANT,
YOU SICK BASTARD?
YOU WANTED TO SEE...
WHAT HE SAW EVERY DAY...
ONLY CLOSER...
CLOSER.
HE WAS CLOSE TO HOME.
[groaning loudly]
THERE'S OUR MAN.
- ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO GET HIM.
GO, GO!
- HOW DID YOU--
VAUGHAN, THAT WAS AMAZING.
I'M SORRY THAT I DOUBTED YOU.
YOUR METHODS
ARE UNORTHODOX, BUT...
I CANNOT ARGUE
WITH YOUR RESULTS.
[zipper closes]
- NO HARD FEELINGS?
- UH, NO, NOPE,
NOT GONNA DO THAT.